>> Jason: THE BIG QUESTION
AFTER THE LATEST BOMBSHELL
REVELATION IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION IS HOW WILL
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACT.
WE NOW THOUGH KNOW THAT DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE PAUL MANAFORT FOR
POTENTIAL COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA
OR UKRAINE.
THAT INFORMATION WAS IN A PARTLY
REDACTED AND FORMERLY SECRET
GOVERNMENT MEMO FILED IN COURT
BY SPECIAL PROSECUTOR BOB
MUELLER LATE LAST NIGHT.
LET'S EXAMINE THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THIS LATEST REVELATION WITH
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JOHN
DUFFY OF WISCONSIN AND
WASHINGTON ATTORNEY AND
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST SCOTT
BOLTON.
SCOTT, I WANT TO GO TO YOU
FIRST.
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS REALLY
JUSTIFIED?
PHYSICAL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION?
WHAT IN THE WORLD WITH UKRAINE
HAVE TO DO WITH THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION ON THE ELECTION OF
2016?
>> IS A FORMER PROSECUTOR AND
SOMEONE WHO DEFENDED PEOPLE
IN THE CLINTON INVESTIGATIONS,
LET ME JUST SAY THIS, NOT ONLY
THINK IS GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION, BUT IF THE
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE AUTHORIZED
IT.
NOT JUST ROSENSTEIN BUT THE
ORIGINAL ORDER THAT WAS GIVEN TO
MUELLER FOR HIS INVESTIGATION
WAS TO INVESTIGATE COLLUSION OR
COORDINATION BETWEEN THESE
PARTIES, EITHER BEFORE OR AFTER
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
ROSENSTEIN, EVEN UNDER THE CODE
OF FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS, THEY
ARE JUST FOLLOWING WHERE THE
EVIDENCE TAKES THEM.
>> Jason: I WANT TO GO TO THE
GRAPHIC.
THE ORIGINAL LETTER THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN SENT TO MUELLER
AUTHORIZING HIS INVESTIGATION,
THERE ARE THREE POINTS TO THIS.
IF WE CAN PUT IT UP ON THE
SCREEN.
NUMBER TWO ON THIS POINT IS ANY
MATTERS THAT AROSE OR MAY ARISE
DIRECTLY FROM THE INVESTIGATION
AND CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, I WAS
PLEASED AND HONORED TO SERVE
WITH YOU IN THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS.
BUT POINT NUMBER TWO SAYS THAT
ANY MATTERS THAT AROSE OR MAY
ARISE DIRECTLY FROM THE
INVESTIGATION, THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WOULD SUGGEST THAT
MAYBE THE DEMOCRATS WERE THE
ONES THAT WERE ACTUALLY
COLLUDING.
DO YOU SEE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
MUELLER IS ACTUALLY PURSUING
THAT PART OF THIS INVESTIGATION?
>> JASON, IT WAS A PLEASURE
SERVING WITH YOU AS WELL.
YOU BRING A GOOD POINT.
I WAS A PROSECUTOR AS WELL.
THE CHARGE THAT MUELLER RECEIVED
WAS TO INVESTIGATE COLLUSION OR
INVOLVEMENT OF RUSSIA AND THE
2016 ELECTION, WHICH MEANS THEY
CAN LOOK AT DONALD TRUMP BUT
THEY CAN ALSO LOOK AT
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE ONLY EVIDENCE THAT WE'VE HAD
COME OUT PUBLICLY IN REGARD TO
CODE COLLUSION IS THE FACT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
COLLUDED THROUGH FUSION GPS AND
CHRIS DIVERSE DEAL WITH
RUSSIA, THEY PAID RUSSIAN
INFORMANTS WITH DOUBLE, TRIPLE,
QUADRUPLE HEARSAY TO CRAFT A
DOSSIER THAT THE FBI USED TO GO
AFTER DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT RUSSIA
COLLUSION AND RUSSIAN INFLUENCE,
YOU GOT TO LOOK HILLARY CLINTON
AND WHAT THEY DID IN CRAFTING
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES, IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT MUELLER IS
LOOKING AT THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
>> Jason: SCOTT, DO YOU THINK
THE CONGRESSMAN HAS A POINT?
DO YOU SEE THE EVIDENCE OF MY
FRUSTRATION FROM THE REPUBLICANS
ARE SAYING, HOW COME THE PURSUIT
OF JUSTICE IS ONLY IN ONE
DIRECTION?
IT'S A ONE WAY STREET?
WHY NOT LOOK AT WHAT THE
CONGRESSMAN JUST SAID?
>> JASON, IT IS NOT A ONE-WAY
STREET.
IT IS INCOMPARABLE.
THE MEETINGS, ALL THE
INFORMATION, THE GUILTY PLEAS
THAT HAVE COME OUT OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION --
>> Jason: THEY HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH COLLUSION.
>> THEY HAVE A DIRECT MANDATE TO
LOOK AT THE COORDINATION BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
LET ME GET HILLARY CLINTON
BECAUSE THE REPUBLICANS LOVE TO
JUMP ON AND JUMPED BACK TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
DO YOU THINK HILLARY CLINTON
OUGHT TO BE INVESTIGATED?
THE REPUBLICANS WERE ON THE
HOUSE, SENATE, AND WHITE HOUSE.
TWO CONGRESSMAN, ONE SENATOR AND
CONGRESSMAN, SENT A LETTER TO
DOJ COME WITH A JEFF SESSIONS,
ASKING THEM TO INVESTIGATE.
IF THEY DON'T INVESTIGATE, THAT
MEANS EITHER THERE IS NOTHING
THERE OR THEY ARE TOO BUSY
FOCUSING ON THE OTHER PART --
>> Jason: YOU DO SEE THAT
THERE WAS MORE THAN $10 MILLION
THAT WENT OUT THE DOOR THERE.
SORRY, CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, GO
AHEAD.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE
PARTISAN HACKS AT THE HEAD OF
THE DOJ AND FBI.
THAT IS WHY I'VE CALLED FOR A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO LOOK AT THE
PARTISANSHIP.
>> AND IT HAS BEEN REJECTED.
>> I THINK ALL AMERICANS WILL
SAY, WHAT INVOLVEMENT DID RUSSIA
HAVE IN THE ELECTIONS?
I'M ON THE SAME PAGE.
WE WANT TO FIND THAT OUT.
LET'S NOT DO IT IN A PARTISAN
WAY.
LET'S NOT JUST LOOK AT
DONALD TRUMP.
THERE IS A LOT OF SMOKE AND I
THINK THERE IS FIRE TO LOOK AT
HILLARY CLINTON, AS WELL.
IF YOU ONLY LOOK AT ONE SIDE OF
THIS ISSUE ARE NOT THE OTHER,
THAT IS WHY THERE ARE SO MANY
REPUBLICANS FEELING LIKE IT'S A
PARTISAN INVESTIGATION.
>> I DO BELIEVE THIS.
I DEEPLY BELIEVE THAT IF MUELLER
FINDS INFORMATION, WHETHER IT'S
A SMOKE, FIRE, EVIDENCE, FACTS,
THAT HILLARY CLINTON SOMEHOW
COORDINATED, NOTWITHSTANDING THE
CONJECTURE OF WHAT THE
CONGRESSMAN THINKS, I THINK HE'S
GOT THE AUTHORITY TO LOOK AT IT
OR TO ASK ROSENSTEIN --
>> WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID RUSSIA TO
DEVELOP THIS DIRTY DOSSIER THAT
WAS USED AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
>> THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
>> THERE'S $10 MILLION -- WE
SHOULD LOOK AT HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Jason: I THINK SCOTT
ACTUALLY BRINGS UP A GOOD POINT.
I DO BELIEVE THAT SCOTT BRINGS A
BIGGER POINT.
YOU HAVE FOUR KEY SENATORS OUT
THERE, YOU HAVE TREY GOWDY, BOB
GOODLATTE, TWO CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE, CALLING FOR A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
JIM JORDAN AND MARK MEADOWS HAVE
BEEN CALLING THIS FOR MONTHS.
AND THEY STILL WON'T DO IT.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, TO PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE AISLE, IT
IS A MYSTERY BECAUSE IT DOES
SEEM LIKE IT'S A ONE-WAY STREET.
>> I AM NOT AFRAID OF IT.
I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS
SHOULD BE.
LET THE INVESTIGATION RUN ITS
COURSE.
>> YOU DO UNDERSTAND THIS POINT
VERY WELL.
JASON, YOU ARE THE CHAIRMAN OF
INVESTIGATIONS AND THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
WHEN YOU TRIED TO GET
INFORMATION FROM THE FBI AND
DOJ, DID THEY COOPERATE WITH
YOU?
THAT THEY PROVIDE THE EVIDENCE
THAT YOU ASKED FOR AS AND
EMPOWERED INDIVIDUAL IN
CONGRESS, TO DO OVERSIGHT?
THEY DON'T PROVIDE IT TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THEY
DON'T PROVIDE IT TO BOB
GOODLATTE AND THEY DO CHEER
COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE NOT COOPERATING EVEN
WITH OUR INVESTIGATIONS, WHICH
MAKES YOU SCRATCH YOUR HEAD AND
SAY, WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO
HIDE FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND CONGRESS?
>> Jason: I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE LAST WORD, SCOTT BRADY
WANTED TO CONSIDER THIS.
IT IS A CLOSED INVESTIGATION.
THERE HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAS IN
PLACE SINCE 2016 AND STILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL NOT
OPEN UP THE FILES ON A CLOSED
CASE.
I WOULD THINK THAT YOU, YOU ARE
VERY ACCOMPLISHED IN A
REASONABLE PERSON, WOULD
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR I
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR S
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR T
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR O
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR E
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR R
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR P
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR U
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR T
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR O
UNDERSTAND HOW PATENTLY UNFAIR F
JUSTICE AND OVERSIGHT TO NOT
TURN OVER THOSE DOCUMENTS AND
ALLOW CONGRESSMAN ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE TO REVIEW THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
>> LET ME TELL YOU THIS.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S FAIR
OR REASONABLE BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHY THE REPUBLICANS ARE BRAGGING
OR COMPLAINING BECAUSE YOU HAVE
CONTROL OF ALL THREE HOUSES.
BY THE WAY, CONGRESSMAN AND
SENATORS HAVE A LOT OF LEVERS TO
PULL.
YOU COULD HOLD THEM IN CONTEMPT,
YOU CAN IMPEACH THEM, YOU CAN
FORCE THEM TO TRAIN THESE